[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the future of syphilis
testing improve your workflow with novel
technologies presented by dr. Belinda
Young Lieberman dr. Ellen Wu and dr.
Vera tessick I'm Christina jeweled
elaborate and alter your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
bio-rad laboratories now before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation we will also
be conducting a few polls
the polls will pop up in the middle of
your slide window just check the box
that best describes your answer and
click Submit in fact here is our first
poll what algorithm does your laboratory
currently follow or use is it
traditional algorithm reverse algorithm
or other thanks for your participation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the Q&A button to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits just click on the
button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I would now like to introduce
our presenters dr. Belinda Yin Lieberman
is a professor of pathology at the
Cleveland Clinic Lerner College of
Medicine she's board-certified in
clinical virology dr. Yin Lieberman
received her Bachelor of Science degree
in microbiology from Southern Illinois
University and her Master of Science and
Doctorate degrees in immunology and
biochemistry at the University of
Arkansas Fayetteville
she completed fellowships in clinical
and cellular immunology at case
Western Reserve University and the
Cleveland Clinic Foundation dr. Iain
Lieberman has offered over 130 articles
for numerous medical journals on a wide
range of topics involving viruses and
infectious disease dr. Allen woo is
chief of clinical chemistry and
toxicology at San Francisco General
Hospital professor of Laboratory
Medicine University of California San
Francisco and medical director for the
pharmacogenomics laboratory he received
BS degrees in chemistry and biology at
Purdue University West Lafayette Indiana
in a PhD degree in analytical chemistry
at the University of Illinois Champaign
Urbana Illinois he completed a
postdoctoral fellowship in clinical
chemistry at Hartford Hospital dr. Wu
has over 400 publications in
peer-reviewed journals he has also
written five paperback books consisting
of short stories designed to promote the
value of the clinical laboratory and
pharmacogenomics to the general public
dr. Veera testa quirks as an assistant
professor of pathology an assistant
medical director of clinical
microbiology and immunology laboratories
at the University of Chicago medicine
Chicago Illinois she completed her
training in pathology at the University
of Illinois Chicago followed by a
shallow ship in clinical microbiology at
the University of Utah a RUP
laboratories her areas of interest
include application of new technologies
into clinical laboratory practice an
implementation of cost-effective
diagnostic tests for infectious diseases
with a particular focus on syphilis
testing to read the full biographies on
our speakers please click on their
photos in the top left corner of your
screen I would now like to hand this
presentation over to our speakers
welcome doctors you may now begin your
presentation thank you good morning and
good afternoon to everyone today I would
take the next 15 to 20 minutes to
provide you an overview of currently
available laboratory diagnostic tests
from individuals with syphilis infection
quickly the over the outline will go
over the the O test versus the new test
for syphilis diagnosis and then follow
with the CDC recommendation for the
syphilis diagnostic test quickly we all
know the syphilis is a bacteria called
Triple E meperidine so it's a Spiro T
it's a grand negative bacteria and then
it looked like a corkscrew shade the
cells so like I said so bacteria is very
saying is 6 to 15 micrometer
but it's only 0.1 micrometer Y and then
usually their debate about the grand
thing even though he was decided as a
brand negative but not many people's
fear not quite sure
normally you cannot see you know visibly
with regular microscope so you have to
use what we call dark field microscopy
but in my life in the lab I have never
seen one so so everybody can see this on
the Google on my picture quickly I'll
just briefly remind you know everyone
about epidemiology as you can see from
the next slide in the forties the
prevalence of positive syphilis is
really high so it's you know 500 close
to second six hundred per hundred
thousand people people so as time goes
you know because the not invented
penicillin their treatment to the
prevalence of a really done and here we
get to about nineteen late 80s and 90s
now we have 2017
so the party rate has significant
increase the last many years due to may
have sex with men and many other reasons
so the lab where I work and we do
significant a number of the screening
tests for adolescent and for you know
people in their 20s to 40s and be able
to capture significant number of people
totally asymptomatic but serology
positive and then quickly you showed
this next map so showing the prevalence
in 2010 as you can see on the on the
let's see I want to show people is on
this over here the prevalence is less
than 0.2 over hundred thousand and that
is that's 2010 when you get back to the
next slide again you can see the
prevalence went to 1.0 we are talking
about tenfold increment in the positive
people with positive syphilis test
result
so in 2016-17
and when you check on a CDC website it
has the god fixed for increment since
the last two three years so it's a it's
a worrisome it's a test that never going
to go down again unless we can making
sure everyone gets screened to detect it
that the test would decay to virus over
the bacteria and normally it's
microscopy
a siren you're mentioned early dark
field microscopy is something in the
past unless maybe a CDC and then they we
actually don't that do not do any the
direct immunofluorescent because we
never have any sample that you can
capture positive and no silver stain so
serology text a consists of two kind not
what first one is
Shanina so it's a rapid plasma real gene
what is the in the soleus VDRL venereal
disease research lab both this non
triple nema tests detect the detecting
of antibody against cardiolipin which is
the protein product produced due to high
fever so they are indirect but they are
very accurate in the case where the tech
you know a cube infection right in the
middle infection however does a lot of
force
pass the results this in your four years
does the easy to do so everyone uses a
manual test then the second west trip
animal tests you detect the presence of
anybody ID goig em tour to panama parody
so again the direct dark co and test and
i unless other people still doing that i
do not know so let's go discuss a little
bit non trip aneema test as i say you're
really not detecting the bacteria you're
detecting the product due to the
bacterial infection and it's very
accurate for many years very cheap it
look like pregnancy test type of things
really fast however they are not
specific so it could be forced positive
when you have lyme disease malaria TB I
remember tussle people have pregnancy IV
drug so as a result you can see the list
of nonspecific positive could be you
know sort of giving you a headache
whether what should we do they are only
they have a cardiolipin that's why the
all test algorithm is to do the
nonspecific wearing is equivocal or
force positive then you reflux them to a
trip anemia test at that time was very
expensive and then also you know very or
manually so this test is very good the
RP r and v dr is very good to detect
primary and
secondary syphilis so this next slide
will show you if everyone looks like
pregnancy tests or your mono spa so this
test is the particular gluten ation
detect the presence or anybody against
cardio life and so as you can see this
is a quantitative test this test is very
important
you can quantitate it detect the
presence of the antibody against cardio
life and so the higher the tighter the
more so-called severity of the cases so
you can see this is very tradition and
the next slide also show you we the
cream clinic we still have this we hope
we have this up by 2018 before we bring
in the new tests we're here I joke with
things like shake and bake you shake
this thing you go read the particle
gluten nation but if fear works and
however if you received hundred become
very you know labor intense so let's
talk about trip edema tests the last
many years detection for anybody against
the bacteria become very very popular
because it is syphilis syphilis caused
by trip in your palate II we need to
detect anybody Costa and so there are
many tests available and fluorescent
tripping IVA Paladini anybody absorption
test or trip in Europe alanine particle
agglutination and that's the test that a
lot of people are used for many years
but I'm not quite sure it's FDA cleared
but it's very accurate so we used to
send out two Russians lab the enzyme
immunoassay chemiluminescent even assay
the drugs was the most important
multiplex fluorescing immunoassay is for
we are using a lot of a majority of the
lab they use that because you actually
use recombinant bacterial antigen and
the code on the B's
it's a luminex piece and then you use an
enzyme immunoassay to do the test and
there are also sparta call able so is
increase the sensitivity as the society
tremendous equal reasons we brought that
in five four or five years ago so
quickly next slide quickly review to you
but what's traditional test this is sort
of oh I said to treat so it's the oil
syphilis test test algorithm so when the
sample come in you quickly do it our PR
if the spinal fluid you do the VDRL the
only difference is the concentration or
the antigen and then when isn't negative
and then you can report out at least who
I started they were still using that no
it's a no syphilis or recently infection
all of us know when you first get
infected it takes two to four weeks for
individuals to produce anybody so that
window period that could be negative but
that would be first negative so in this
case if patient has the right no medical
history they have to be follow-up
compared to see the clinician but you're
going to the left side that algorithm
when the are PR or VD are is positive
then you have to confirm with the when
the RPS part confirm with trip anemic
fluorescent trip anemic Aladin test so
you can confer not only the entire
cardio likely is positive patient has a
fever inflammation but this is caused by
trip edema parodying the bacteria which
you confirm is a positive syphilis on
the left side and these negative and
then you know in the leg we're very
cautious we say negative negative
we'll say probably not syphilis so the
next layer is a really standard serology
reactivity on the left side swing the
time you get infected and then you
follow the time and from the x-axis you
can see at what time the antibody will
be produced and also the what time that
anybody against can cardio lighting will
be available
- - for us to be tested so there's again
you see a window period so there are a
lot of times individual could be
asymptomatic and then working around not
knowing for a while if you're young
healthy and there is some my friends
practice in the other hospital say
sometimes they working around they look
perfectly fine physical does not show
then when they do the test they are
finding are PR positive so in those case
this is a test that's very crucial if
you don't offer the patient tests and
then you could have missed someone who
is in the process become convert to
positive so the so the RPL important
confirmatory cysts are important so now
just some sort of positive negative
negative sort of characteristic of this
test the old traditional test is very
cheap low throughput because you're
using your finger making little circles
before that gluten ation is very manual
if every day like we have some time we
have hundred thirty hundred forty and
you can be really labor intense then
it's reliable for detection of active
infection that's really positive and the
RP our interpretation is highly
subjective because I mentioned that it
cross-react when you have other fever
due to herpes
Toxoplasma even pregnancy so that could
be misleading and there were in this
case our clinician here will just ask
for come back retest and to to receive
that the result here persisted so
reverse that's the new reverse sequence
algorithm this were you take the patient
sample you test for the trip anemia
paletine antibody test so is heist
hi supra is automated so we use bio
plaques there are several other
automated ew8 platform people are using
it so this test will detect early
syphilis and the syphilis being
untreated which
is very advantage and then objective
interpretation because the antibody is
positive it is against the syphilis
bacteria so the issues of gore
discordant result I will show you some
example I'm sure from the other left on
the Doctor Who or doctor tactics less we
get things like then then you scratch
your head and you do some kind of repeat
so so the reverse sequence you do right
way where I am we do we do the syphilis
IgG right away and with nonreactive
again not know syphilis or very recent
when you go to the on the left side that
the algorithm you see its reactive then
you confer with our PR why do we confirm
a positive antibody test to syphilis
bacteria with our PR because our PR our
test can be done quantitative so if
patient is positive they've been treated
with penicillin and then they get
periodically
come in and get a sample and get
retested see if the penicillin is
working that's when you will observe
titer slowly going down and so instead
going up so your the patients on the
right track a proper treatment so it's a
very important to tell the doctor at
what stage your patient is after they
being treated so if the RPI started the
syphilis anybody's positive then the
results positive syphilis then by if if
the syphilis antibody tests positive R
PR negative you have a question like it
could be someone just have a low immune
response you know they don't make enough
anybody or whatever reason or they could
be forced negative it is right at the
cutoff so in at the Cleveland Clinic
whoever we get positive syphilis test
negative R P R we go right to a second
syphilis fda-cleared assist anybody test
and then just sort of double confirm
the second trip aneema test with the
first move and they are two different
manufacturer and then they're a little
bit different little bit different in
the sensitivity the second test is more
sensitive and then the first test it's
the first test it's more specific so so
here we talk about disgorging result you
will think such a simple in fashion you
get a lot of discordant result someone's
passed the trip aneema negative I just
mentioned that to you and maybe they are
treated maybe they have latent syphilis
and they were also early fashion with
syphilis there anybody is not around
here and also paths that could be many
case false positive trigger minitest i'd
be quick we have an example so we have a
83 year old woman impatient in the
nursing home and when they test her she
was positive but she was little bit
above the cutoff so our ID doctor is
really worried now because she's in
nursing home and what no what would you
do when you see this and you want to
retest so we retest
she was there positive and so finally
the clinician actually to make things
you know she's not quite sure that sort
of related with acne active sexual
activity or things like that so she she
just went ahead treat a patient then we
followed the patient as time went and
actually we saw the RTR number you know
there was negative but he was always
stay negative but the positive the true
Ponemah test slowly went down after a
year too so
so sometimes weight in laboratory can
use our this will be our tool to be the
repeater test redraw and check other you
know medical history can help to you
know survey's resolve the conflict
result so so they're pros cons i think
this is repeater we already mentioned
you know inexpensive low throughput
manual and based reliable it is active
and the RTR
interpretation is subjective with
bearing in mind so mixture patient
doesn't have the other infection and and
then reverse the new test algorithm is
high school less manual actually cheaper
in our case and then can detect early
syphilis and the surface being untreated
and the objective interpretation because
the test you know the antigen were all
recombinant so it's less cross
reactivity with other infections like
herpes or toxin and then there a lot of
to do with patient management on this
gorgeou reason I'm sure both dr. rule
and dr. Tessa both have to send cases
like we have so now there's some just
got a new comparison so in United States
a lot of Hospital Public Health steer
use the O algorithm but because they
work also the Rawlings not high so they
were used the are PR and then like in
our place we do know hundreds so we use
the reverse up here but you can see the
accuracy then there's a third ones the
European algorithm from what I was
taught I think I was told the European
algorithm they used to trip anemic the
AEI a test they used to one after
another and to increase their accuracy
so that's also good maybe more expensive
so quickly hopefully I'm not taking too
long but quickly so the CDC issue
recommendation year end of 2015 they
recommend non tripping Amata's being
repeat in two to four weeks for the
patient at risk for primary syphilis and
and secondly the optimal a second test
should be a trip animal pelleting
doesn't you know the particle goose
nation and that's for those times before
we found us a second trip Ponemah a
syphilis or antigen test anybody says
we will send allow and then now we use
the second FDA
proved and so this is the whoever
discord and you use the second one so
the patient can have two syphilis test
and yrp are the non terminal test is
recommend to monitor patient treatment
because the titer after our PR can
change if someone titers were 164 can
you eventually go really done they're
actually indicate to the clinician that
patients are making progress and recover
and so the last question one last
question is there a way to have both
tripping 'man entrepreneurs are some
intentional simultaneously so for the
past few years more I was there for that
you know a lab director I keep thinking
you're this there they are doing just
look like or they shake a baby or you
smear them look like prepping pregnancy
test your way very labor intense then
you'll go get a tube you do the second
test so I think and then I think the
audience would be pleasantly surprised
it is coming and actually it's FDA
cleared and here's the Machine we use is
rendering access and it's easy to
operate is complete automated so quickly
the syphilis remains a diagnostic and
diagnosis required combination
laboratory test and of course King
clinical you know observation the
reverse sequence test syphilis tests
have Kiev ng over the conventional one
and in the early phase of implementation
like what we did we must be prepared to
educate and inform a clinician because
we actually gave the talk in both
pediatric and that bowel infection
disease and that we invited and asked
question and the laboratory maybe must
be open to altering the test algorithm
to best serve the clinician we're we're
have a couple of frame working in a
smaller place they actually use the
treat the traditional a syphilis test
because it works better for them and
their value is very low which I agree
with in hundred-percent so you have to
be very flexible to do to work with the
clinician and then your patient
population - you know not to do
unnecessary tests the issue in your last
lastly the additional study compared
that different to Panama as they barely
needed so this is the end of my talk and
now I turn in this to dokku well thank
you dr. Yin Lieberman so my job is to
talk about the bio Plex assay both the
total and RP r is part of the clinical
trial that was submitted to the fda and
received 510 K clearance we were one of
the trial sites and so we have quite a
bit of experience with this particular
assay so as Belinda indicated she uses
the bow flex 2200 which is a automated
immunoassay system that uses different
colored beads micro beads that are
labeled with fluorescent dye each bead
color is detected by one color of the
laser and then these are fluorescently
labeled so that you can detect the
presence of individual analytes and so
this particular instrument allows for
simultaneous detection from a single set
of beads so the total syphilis and our
PRSA specifications are listed here
it's the 2200 by Plex analyzer it uses
for the Eponine and sa fusion protein
for the RP r it's a cardiolipin antigen
this mitochondrial of lipid a membrane
component there's also an internal
standard bead and a serum verification
bead the conjugate is a monoclonal
anti-gm and I'm sorry IgG and IgM
antibody and as a result you'll get
three results you get the quantitative
total anti-trump animo combination IgG
and IgM result you get the RP r and you
get the RP are tighter this
is a diagram showing the different beads
the blue beads as shown here are the
fusion protein for total syphilis again
both IgG and IgM the anti cardiolipin
antibody is detected using the RP r and
they carry a light that an antigen here
they're all mixed into this cocktail
along with the internal standard bead to
stabilize or thus to standardize the
detector response and a serum
verification B just to verify that in
fact the sample that you're dealing with
is serum the intended you statement
submitted to the FDA is a qualitative
test for syphilis diagnosis it's not
intended for screening blood or plasma
donors a second qualitative step and
either the traditional or reverse
algorithms for syphilis detection is
used can be done in either way on the
bio plaques and then in order to get a
quantitative level there can be up to
five solutions that can determine titers
up to 1 to 64 these are the various
features the sample type can be serum
can be plasma either with EDTA lithium
or sodium heparin very small sample
volume of 10 microliters the results
here qualitative but you do see a
antibody index result for the syphilis
test the reportable range of 0.2 to 8.0
AI and the RP are also with deletions up
to these five different titers one to
four through one to 64 and the RP our
signal is ranges of 0.2 to 10 antibody
index the interpretation is given here
for the total syphilis
there is a reactive zone of greater than
or equal to one point one there is the
non reactive zone of less than or equal
to 0.8 and there is a equivocal zone any
values between 0.9 and 1.0 are so listed
and for our PR anything that is less
than a 1.0 is considered nonreactive and
greater than that would be greater than
1.0 greater than or equal to 1.0 so here
are some data on the our PR tighter
interpretations the various five on
board solutions that are performed and
the final result as indicated here on
the far right would be the tighter that
produced the of the last reactive result
so for example here if we have a value
of 1 to 32 then that would be the last
dilution that would be reactive for that
particular specimen the FDA trial
consisted of three clinical sites two
internal sites and one at the
manufacturer samples collected in 2008
and the predicate devices were the
company sa the TPPA the manual our PR
and the EIA essays compared to the bio
flex approximately 1,900 samples were
tested on the Flex 2200 syphilis total
and our PR assays with results and
concordance evaluated these were broken
down into samples that were collected
prospectively
that is to say tests that were ordered
on either apparently healthy individuals
pregnant women HIV patients and also a
set of 540 samples that were
retrospectively collected which included
both positive and clinically diagnosed
syphilis the prospective study the
intended use population were those on
whom a syphilis algorithm was ordered or
that they had HIV positivity or that the
women was pregnant
dr. yen Lieberman showed you data on our
PR indicating that many patients who
have an HIV infection or who have who
are pregnant can produce a false
positive result for the our PR and this
was why those particular groups or
especially highlighted in this study so
here are the raw data the prospective
samples for those on whom tests were
ordered you can see the bio plex 2200
here in the top and the syphilis total
and on the bottom the our PR because the
syphilis has an equivocal zone there are
handful of patients that are in that
zone and overall against the predicate
the percent positive agreement was
ninety two point five percent and
percent negative agreement ninety seven
point nine percent for the total
syphilis sa and eighty one point five
for the RP are against the predicate and
ninety six point five against the
predicate for the negative ninety eighty
one point five positive agreement ninety
six point five negative agreement
breaking down the groups according to
pregnant women of smaller numbers as you
can see but the performance was equal to
and in many cases superior and these are
the retrospective performances again a
smaller subset those who were clinically
positive many more of them here and you
can see excellent positive agreements
well over ninety eight percent in all
cases and finally the HIV specific
population again a population that can
produce false positive results on the AR
PRSA we see excellent agreement
positively at ninety three percent at
ninety four percent for negative
agreement with the syphilis total si
so these data confirm the diagnostic
utility of the confirmatory tests for
both the troponin and non trepan and
screening procedures that using either
the traditional algorithm at 99.8%
positive agreement or the reverse
algorithm where the bio flex RP RSA is
the first essay done in the reverse
algorithm and that was near 96 percent
positive agreement as a laboratory you
have really your option of doing
whichever procedure that you feel it is
best useful for your institution this is
the comparison of the two algorithms the
traditional on the top where our PR is
done first then followed up by a
predicate test either the TTP a or the
bio plexus and the percent agreement
here are shown at 99.8% for a positive
result and 80 7.5% for a negative second
test if you do the reverse algorithm
whether you use the TPPA first as your
screening test followed by our PR and
confirmed by the bio Plex our PR or you
do the EIA first or chemiluminescence
immunoassay followed by the our PR again
excellent agreements particularly for
the positive TPPA and positive our PR
the precision of the assays on the bio
Plex 2200 is excellent somewhere between
2 to 6 percent or within and 2 to 10
percent for between imprecision
particular essay was tested against a
host of different potential interference
this slide here shows the typical
interferences that we do in the
laboratory haemoglobin bilirubin lipids
proteins showing really no interferences
with these essays any more specific
interference test against cross
activities to other infectious disease
serologies as you see here CMV the anti
cardio life and antibodies are not
directed towards the ones in the are PR
but are directed against those that are
produced in autoimmune disease and again
you can see rubella very little cross
reactivity to other serologies with the
total and RP our bio flex 22s 100 sa so
the conclusion for the FDA was that this
file access a shows substantial
equivalence to other commercially
available predicate assays and the essay
was approved by the FDA and is now
available for use now I just have a
couple of additional slides of some data
that that we have generated from this
trial this is a chart of a series of
individuals nine individuals on whom
there were multiple bleeds and the first
line would be the first day bleed and
then the subsequent lines would be
bleeds on days five ten thirteen
thirty-one etc after the first bleed and
these would indicate the seroconversion
of syphilis over time and the results of
various predicate assays as well as the
bio flexuz ability to detect the first
positivity
now dr. Yin Lieberman indicated that
there is this window period here where
there can be some assays that are
negative when yet the person
is infected and potentially falsely
presumed to be not infected and if you
look at the first column here the by
Alexa Phyllis it is consistently either
the earliest or equal to in terms of the
earliest than any of the other Treponema
and non-trump animo assays compared for
example 14 days earlier than the Arbit
architects the trinity biotech Captiva
which is the IG MSA the IgG I say we
actually expect it to be later
developing because the Cyril conversion
rate is is low again the bio plex
measures both IgM and IgG a Trinity
assure trap and the DSO in liaison so
each of these are either equal to or
superior to the other predicate assays
and this other slide rather complex
slide looks at some of the raw data for
four different samples there's the
negative control the positive control
one sample that is weakly positive and
another sample that is strongly positive
each of these samples were assayed
twenty times there is 100% agreement
with the result on all of the samples
and on the second line of each entry is
the precision of the antibody index so
with the cutoff being 1.0 is indicated
at the bottom and you can see here that
when the values are very low the
interchange is a little bit higher but
still well below 20% even for the
negative control and then for the
positive samples it's well below 5% this
shows excellent precision that you
really cannot get with any of the other
manual assays for either trepan Eponine
or non Treponema tests and then this is
a dilution guide so that we are able to
on board do five solutions and depending
on which of the dilution
which of the results of the index is
positive would then equate to a titer
that people are used to seeing when it
comes to the r PR card so for example
the third one if you have a reactive
value of 4.0 that would indicate that
the the titer would be one to eight and
then if it's greater than ten then it's
at least one to 64 so in summary the bio
Plex
2200 syphilis total and RP RSA show
substantial performance equivalence two
other commercially tests for terminal
Treponema and non trap animal I would
argue that in some cases it's actually
superior in terms of producing an
earlier seropositivity
it that can be used to test both the r
PR and the total si simultaneously on
the same sample on the same instrument
and allows you to use whichever
algorithms that your infectious disease
people or your clinical laboratory are
comfortable with whether it is the
reverse or the traditional algorithm I
would argue and I think that what we're
going to hear in our next talk from Vera
tesak that there are advantages of
considering the use of the reverse
algorithm so without any further ado I
will turn over the presentation to dr.
tesak all right thank you dr. rule
I'm going to talk about our experiences
with our evaluation of dialogues 2250
total and our PR se at University of
Chicago Medicine so what can the county
does to automate our syphilis testing
there are many benefits of automated
platform for syphilis syphilis testing
your nurse similar to automation of
other Isis because there is objective
and automated screening approach there
is also increased sample throughput
objects are ergonomically issues and
there is also limitation of observer
variability with all manual acids and
with that we also have reduction of
manual labor and ultimately rehab cost
decrease and at the endpoint we with
automation we also have LS connectivity
which every minute clerical error
besides wanting to automate our syphilis
testing bringing on board baths of 2200
allowed us to consolidate testing of
other analytes that are available on
this platform and replace many Isis
either a lifestyle or in United States I
estate and agglutination acid that we
previously performed on different
instruments or manually in our lab or
laboratory
the advantage is important to us to
random access with the additional bonus
that control for each analyte is done
once once a day and we're just batching
the tasks and needing to run control
each time this system can automatically
process up to 100 samples per hour and
depending on the Isis and first results
can be very quickly available
approximately in 40 to 60 minutes
subsequent patient samples were
completely every 30 seconds so in 2014
we performed traditional testing
algorithm so the traditional algorithm
in our laboratory consisted of change
with the RP are not
to name out that that was done as manual
agglutination test in confirmation of
reactive results with Japanese notice in
our laboratory was FDA ABS response to
therapy was followed by our PR title
usually six to twelve months after the
treatment or sooner is necessary and as
you can see in 2014 we performed more
than 8000 manual RTR essays
approximately 700 per month our
confirmatory FDA ABS was also performed
in-house and we also had 17% for
positive R PR in the mid 2015 we
switched to the reverse syphilis testing
algorithm initial screen is for
detection of official strategy
antibodies performed on by plugs 2200
system the simultaneously detects IgG
antibodies to multiple japonica pallidum
proteins confirmation of syphilis is
done with manual are theoretically in
the reverse algorithm discordant
laboratory results for example reactive
Treponema test the negative are PR are
resolved with the second triple you know
test and we switch to the polymer podium
particular about nation active again
response to therapy was followed by RTR
title so as you can see in 2016 we had
more than 10,000 syphilis test requests
and not a number of false positive rate
dropped from 17 percent to 10 percent
with the implementation of the reverse
algorithm increase in the number of
screening tests reflects this rising
tide of Music's cases and increase
demand of testing so we can probably
expect to see more and more test
requests in the future and with the with
the implementation of the reverse
algorithm be very favorable
reduce certain around time for the first
test if it comes out so the traditional
they took six point six hours for the
RTR screen to be reported to our
patients art and now it takes only two
point five eight hours for the first
essay to be seen in the patient chart
so to summarize our currently testing
algorithm is reverse algorithm the
screen the trip amino acid by Plex 2200
are looking for syphilis IgG and
confirmed with manual R PR and we also
discuss an adult resolved with TTP a so
moving forward in other this year and
via clear the new SC so the objective of
our study was to evaluate this new acid
by plus 2203 so is total and our PR so
which team autonomously detects both
Trapani melanin Trapani MOA antibody
team provides our PR tighter up to 64
also detects IgG and IgM antibodies
against the Ponemah pallidum and also
non Trapani malaria our agonized about
this
so basically lubricants tip implemented
says he will be able to utilize either
traditional or reverse testing algorithm
and still have both tests automated with
faster turnaround time increased
throughput and improve workflow so you
see it's we started testing for syphilis
totin an OCR in September 2017
and he tested almost 400 sample then we
compared current facility IgG versus
Italy total results we had ninety four
point one percent of agreement for
detection of positive results and
ninety-nine point seven for the negative
result however when we compared manual
RP our contest results versus five
archaea they had eighty-seven point one
percent of agreement with positive
results for detection of our PR
antibodies and 91.9% for negative
results when we investigated the cause
for lower agreement responded warden
wine and week titles that are one to one
or one to two on manual our PR VD card
specimens we want to patients with
remote history of treated t so it's
either or without it HIV infection so
detection of positive results in these
patients is a little clinical feel it is
significant therefore we felt confident
to remove these specimens which were
borderline without borderline tightest
on manual tests and our percentage of
agreement was higher than up to ninety
four point four for the acute syphilis
that were in either primary or secondary
stage we also calculated turnaround time
and not just for a first people excited
but to complete diagnosis so current
turnaround time is eight hours and if
this is total is implemented it would be
three hours this is total of five hours
reduction that the clinicians you'll get
the results sooner so this young
workflow advantages with new i said if
the new assays used are reduction of
manual labor and we can also dedicate
how technologies time to perform under
si there is better reproducibility and
accuracy of results and what is also
important to us methods are consolidated
on one platform and also there is allies
connectivity for both testing in
conclusion there is a good agreement
with previous LC for detection of
patients in primary and secondary over a
three stages of infection diagnosis is
obtained a three hours faster
Sifu is total and our PR allows both
Treponema and entrepreneur mo assets to
be automated which is a great advantage
thank you and I'll be ready for
additional question for your informative
presentation now before we start our
live Q&A portion of the webinar we have
another poll
are you considering changing your
algorithm in the near future just click
on yes in less than one year yes in one
to two years yes in more than two years
or no thank you again for participating
ok now if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for but if we are not able to get
to your question due to time constraints
your questions will be answered via
email following the presentation ok
let's get started
dr. Yan Lieberman this first question is
for you okay Robert would like to know
when you have a trap positive and are
pure negative that is TPP aid confirmed
should you follow up with our PR in two
weeks ok the question is if we have the
second trip aneema test positive the
clinician usually follow-up two to four
weeks to retest the patient making sure
there's no false positive that that's
mostly routinely for them to follow
usually to do four to the four weeks
that's what I was told
thank you dr. Wu this next question is
for you in our laboratory we tend to
have samples that have our PR titers
greater than 1 to 64 how would I manage
those samples yeah so right now you'll
have to do those delusions by hand by
red ball Plex only
allows right now for five deletions and
up to 1 to 64 but I do know that they
are working on a solution that will
allow titers up to 1 to 2048 so for the
moment we'll have to hold on and do this
manually but that's something that's
going to be fixed very nurser thank you
doctor blue I'd like to ask you this
next question we have an audience member
that didn't quite understand the bio
Plex our PR dilutions guide slide you
mentioned that at a 4.0 ai that i
suggested titer is 1 to 8 yes that is
correct
from that table for the five different
titers that the bio Plex are able to do
online the maximum tighter for for a AI
of four is one to eight
thank you dr. Wu dr. tastic this next
question is for you Robert would like to
know is it appropriate to compare an RP
are tighter versus bio Plex cardio lipid
tighter particularly as you could see
with our data there is a good
correlation with the viperox our PR and
manual RT our tightest however we saw
some discrepancy for borderline either
weak positive or weak reactive samples
and we could attribute this to
difference in methods specifically
because there is subjectivity
interpretation of manual agouti nation
versus something that's done on the
machine and it also has like cut off
this the told already
I believe 0.9 so when you see different
methodologies they were always always
different between themselves
thank you dr. tesak dr. Dan Lieberman
I'd like to ask you this question Xavier
would like to know is it not necessary
to discriminate among i GG and IgM
yeah we all know when idea went sideways
ID and posit are detected which is very
rare by mr. infection solution and the
IgG is sometimes for life forever
so in our experience we rarely get AGM
and you have to catch the right time so
as a result the answer you see yeah
there's clinical said differently to IgG
IgM however in a routine clinical lab so
we do few thousands a year
we rarely it would be preferred by three
months we never have any so the answer
is that yes clinical significance but we
rarely have it since we are doing trip
anemic tests but you know as a first
because the reverse elbows and we are
testing anyway we figure we will not
miss anyone who's in the middle
infection one way or the other
these are good at right thank you dr.
Yan Lieberman dr. woo I would like to
ask you this next question which method
will be preferred ten years from now
traditional or reverse algorithm wow
that's uh that's putting myself on the
spot here well I actually think that the
reverse algorithm is going to be the way
to go because our PR was really
something as a screening test and it was
cheaper and easier but now that we can
do these other tests about the same
effort it seems to me that the reverse
algorithm would be best but you know I
would love to hear that comment from dr.
Lieberman well use you back to who you
made a good point when you give you a
slide showing the syphilis total can
have both results so why are we worried
we've got those there anyway so whether
you said that beautifully you can if you
you like reverse do it
you don't like reverse our PR results
already there Thank You doctors dr. woo
this one's going to come to you again
does bio flex 2200 syphilis work with
draw
blood spots um no not at the moment I
think that's not something that
anybody's really interested in I haven't
heard anybody looking to do that perhaps
maybe with samples that are being sent
through the mail but doing these kinds
of things is actually pretty difficult
I'm involved with the California newborn
screening program and and we use dried
blood spots all the time but but not for
syphilis
Thank You dr. what we're one minute for
one at you one more time is the bio Plex
RP are susceptible to pros oh no effect
no hmm that is because the SA is a
two-step immunoassay with a wash step in
between the two incubations and so
unlike a lot of the other essays like
for specific proteins when we use
nephelometry we don't have a pro zone
effect here for the 2200 thank you dr.
Wu now we have time for one more
question and dr. yan lieberman i'm going
to give you this one Herman says we get
a lot of physicians asking the why as to
the the discrepant results of the trip
positive RP r negative second trip
negative is there a standard answer or
just recommend to repeat testing after a
period of time and what is the typical
percent of discrepancies I don't know
what typical percent discrepancy but all
of us all for this test for the past
many years get that so just think about
we measure antibody antibody level of
the patient or this organism is
fluctuate so sometimes let me give you
example I was taking oral steroids if
they happen to draw a blood there can be
there anybody you know surely after that
can be very low if so it fluctuates so
it's important to tell the patient since
you have a discrepant to come back
repeat with a new sample and then in the
case me Oleg are you taking any
medication you know things like they're
also your people post transplant the
they don't have anybody there taking you
know a dog to build up the immune
response however we get those kind of
patient with that background the
clinical picture is very important and
it's always important to reschedule
repeat a new sample Thank You dr. young
Lieberman and thank you to dr. Wu and to
dr. tessick we have time for just a few
final comments would everybody like to
leave some final comments for our
audience okay
not necessary well I would like to once
again thank dr. Belinda Yan Lieberman
dr. Ellen Wu and dr. Vera tested for
their presentations I would also like to
thank lab roots and bio-rad laboratories
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye bye bye